die union cdu csu stehen in einer neuen
umfrage von forsa nur noch bei sage und
schreibe 19 prozent helmut kohl wüsste
gar nicht ob das ein wert für die fdp
oder für die grünen möglicherweise ist
aber wenn er wüsste dass seine union bei
9 prozent steht und ja ich glaube sie 19
prozent müssen der weckruf sein der
startschuss für eine total inventur bei
cdu und csu denn diese partei ist extrem
wichtig für deutschland die partei stand
in ihrer vergangenheit für klare kante
die stand für eine totale und
unverbrüchliche westbindung sie stand
auch für wohlstand für alle das heißt
dieses land ist eigentlich immer gut
gefahren wenn es eine starke union gibt
diese starke union gibt es definitiv
nicht mehr und deswegen muss kräftig
aufgeräumt werden die union muss sich
fragen warum sie so viel zuspruch
verloren hat und sie muss sicherstellen
dass künftig viel mehr externe also
beispielsweise auch ein frank theelen
eine vivien wohl ein michael nast die
chance haben in der partei aktiv zu
werden um ihre ideen ihre programme ihre
forschung einzubringen um eine lebendige
partei zu sein und der klüngel der
besser stattgefunden hat der muss
aufhören genau dieses aufräumen können
sie am besten in der position machen
denke ich mal also das wird dieser zu
dieser zustand ist für mich völlig
folgerichtig also das ist ja peinlich
was hier abgelaufen ist also diese leute
stellen sie haben sie in den letzten
letzten monaten hier eine performance
geliefert da haben sich ja nicht anders
verdient dass er jetzt diese zahlen habe
was genau ist also vom wahlkampf fair
oder was die kollegen gemacht haben
genauso also erhalten jetzt diese corona
geschichte sind diese pandemie
geschichte da habe ich um diese zum
kumpel auch von paul einfach gesagt ja
jetzt ist denn man macht ja mal
wahlversprechen und und und meine wahl
zu gewinnen und jetzt ist es aber
umgekehrt das müssen wir vorher was
machen um diese wahl zu gewinnen und es
aber wenn es wenigstens wahlversprechen
geben würde dass er bisher an mir am
besten im gedächtnis befinden sich im
wahlversprechen ist das
planungsverfahren beschleunigt werden
sollen also ich gerade gesagt als ich
glaube als gerade
du bist politik experte aber ich glaube
als krone lief und sie da geliefert
haben da waren die werte er sehr sehr
hoch für die für die union also ich
glaube was hier in meiner meinung nach
schief gegangen ist ist der wahlkampf
also es war einfach so dass sie sich
vorher auch ganz klar ja mit vielen
runden selber zerfleischt haben erst ak
und dann der mit bekommen dann kam noch
mal markus söder von der seite ich
glaube das war einfach das haben die
leute gemerkt dass es eben kein team
mehr ist sie haben es vielleicht auch zu
siegessicher gefühlt weiß ich nicht ich
glaube es mag auch absolute kritik an
der cdu der union generell geben aber
ich glaube warum die werte gerade so
schlecht sind das ist weil der wahlkampf
so schlecht ist der ist einfach wirklich
der mann nicht progressiv der war nicht
vereint da sind auch über unglückliche
dinge passiert wie das wie dieses lachen
da im hintergrund das war einfach muss
man auch sagen das sind auch keine guten
bilder bilder ist will ich gar nicht
persönlich anlasten aber dass da muss
man auch ein bisschen darauf achten
genau und ich glaube der wahlkampf ist
ist das sind die 19 wer meinen eindruck
da sind sie haben ja keinen sie haben
jetzt endlich kennen kein ersatz für
merkel das ist genau es wurde einfach
der falsche kandidat aufgestellt das
finde ich ist das problem du bist doch
rheinländerin wie wir in düsseldorf
armin laschet china aber ich finde der
macht teilweise zu ricaner bei anstalten
andere themen das merkt man halt einfach
also lachen im hintergrund so einer
situation das ist für mich ein ding der
unmöglichkeit
interessantes jahr steuern meyer hat ja
auch gelacht ja ja genau ich muss also
natürlich war das ein unschönes bild
aber am ende des tages was mir
eigentlich fehlt ist dass man mehr auf
die echten programme auf guckt und das
war es armin laschet an sich macht und
ich lebe auch im rheinland ist
eigentlich eine gute politik also ist es
jetzt mein superstar finde ich der ist
immer der macht genau alles richtig aber
er ist ein teamplayer und ich finde
schon dass er eigentlich eine solide und
gute gute politik macht dann wenn man
sich das programm seinen festungs planus
weiter anguckt ist das gut was er
wirklich bis jetzt nicht so auf die orte
war umweltschutz muss man ganz klar
sagen es passt
ja der entwicklungsplan muss ja
eigentlich in drei oder vier harten
worten oder zumindest total wurzen
botschaften schlepper gewähren also man
sagen entwicklungsplan fotobuch internet
für alle beispielsweise jaja steuern
runter für jeden gründer oder gar keine
steuer für jeden gründer oder was
kriminelle clans ausweisen sofort also
dann hätte man zumindest botschaften bei
olaf scholz weiß man die mindestens
zwölf euro sichere renten ob das gut da
ärger um lehmann aber ergebnisse
schafften ich glaube das versteht und
bei der union muss man sagen leider gar
nicht sieht ich bin glaube ich wirklich
wieder bei den bei den kandidaten
bekommen ich glaube da der wählen die
leute auch kurzfristig was auch okay es
wieder wissen genug ist wahlkampf und
olaf scholz ist meinung nach auch der
der große gewinner jetzt anscheinend
weil er einfach auch neben zwei anderen
kandidaten steht die beide wirklich
viele fehler gemacht habe ich glaube
auch annalena baerbock hat viele fehler
gemacht und er war immer der der in der
mitte der ganz ruhig war der auch nicht
viel gesagt hat zusatz mein eindruck und
am ende des tages ist als gewinner raus
geht also so krasse botschaften wie der
gesagt die rente ist sicher was also
sind eine gute botschaft aber ich bin
auch nicht dass olaf scholz jetzt so
ganz ich glaube es hat nicht nur was mit
stolz zu tun für mich ist laschet zuviel
kommunalpolitiker und zu wenig kanzler
das hat man heute auch wieder in der
bundestagsrede gemerkt ich liebe
nordrhein-westfalen und ich liebe sie
aber selbst
immer war schon immer nlb gesagt aber
die meisten deutschen wollen nicht
ständig nrw hört sie wollen nicht
ständig beispiel er tritt auf wie ein
kommunalpolitiker er muss aber kanzler
werden und das ist glaube ich das ganz
große problem fertig konkrete
geschichten und emotionale bilder und
davon endlich verstanden und die union
hat verlernt tor zu schießen wenn wir
mal beim fußball vielleicht bleiben oder
das übersetzen im fußball dann
stand es vielleicht am freitag 0 zu 3 80
minute dann hat armin laschet
eingewechselt als trainer wahrscheinlich
schon zu spät 3 mindestens drei neue
spieler oder drei sammer von denen wir
einigermaßen jetzt wissen wofür sie
stehen unter anderem friedrich merz
jetzt gab es ein tor aber leider die spd
ein tor geschossen als sie ist eines zu
viel er hat eigentlich seitdem überhaupt
nicht geworden aber wir sind jetzt in
der 82 minute
kommen würde wie gegen brasilien an mich
erinnert was man uns den land muss jetzt
jan hat ja eben am ende gesagt hier alle
sollten in die politik gehen mich an der
ausgelassen auch schon deswegen ist auch
gut dass meine leute externe holen
sollte externe köpfe würdest du dir das
antun vielleicht auch als berater
zukunftsteam armin laschet
ich muss ganz ehrlich mal sagen also ich
bin der meinung ich weiß nicht ob mir
ein rede wir sind in einem sind wegen
der wechselstimmung es muss wirklich
eine veränderung passieren aber herrlich
tunis auf politik zugute
muth cdu produzierte das nicht aber
andere ich weiß nicht ob so gut für mein
magen wäre aber das ist ja so stoffen
sehr stressiger job aber ich muss ganz
kurz an und sagen es ist halt so
schlecht ist das problem noch dass die
leute die wähler inzwischen doch ein
bisschen sich mehr informieren als
früher als man gesagt hat okay man hat
diese partei die wählt man sowieso so
ist und radiert ja und heutzutage ich
krieg das ja mit letztendlich die die
diese phrasen dass wir gehört haben
dieses ganze so bildung digitalisierung
und so weiter oder ich bin ja der große
umweltschützer in nrw das sind ja alles
lügen dass das ist ja dass nur phrasen
und die leute wissen bescheid die leute
recherchieren dass und wissen auch
bescheid dass das er sei einfach total
durchschaubar ist dass das da in meiner
letzten zeigen dass eigentlich das
interessanteste duell war eigentlich
habeck und söder das war wirklich cool
und da hat dann wurde angefragt wird es
einschränkungen geben für die
bevölkerung fragt die moderatorin und da
sagt duda nein
lüge und habe etwa kula gesagt es wird
einschränkungen geben aber die bürger
werden sich bemerken dass natürlich auch
falsch aber in erster lesung die
intelligenz eleganter machen aber de
facto das gleiche jürgen trittin hat
auch mal gesagt die eeg-umlage also
diese ökostromumlage die wird nicht
teurer als eine kugel eis im monat wir
wissen ja die man kann schauen wir
eigentlich recht einschätzen wir müssen
die als preise anheben glaube ich ja
aber ich freue mich ja wenn sie von
anderen kanzler dann sind also ich werde
grün
realistisch sagen müssen sie sehr gut
verdienen es war ja
nicht der freund von mir sagte du willst
so die uns diese parteien eigentlich
muss fdp wählen vom einkommen her und
mir gesagt du aber es gab ja damals mal
so einen und visionen jahre die er mir
auch eine sehr starke entlastung für die
leute mit weniger verdienen als
verdienst du wenig oder
naja
[Gelächter]
total ist was du sagst wie den 1 weil
ich glaube wir müssen die politische
debatte haben und ich finde es total
super weil ich da müssen alle mehr und
offener entspannter darüber sprechen wir
haben einfach eine menge gerade glaube
ich fast aggressivität teilweise wenn
man sagt ich bin grün oder ich bin für
die fdp oder die union oder wen auch
immer und ich find's toll dass man sagt
ich will die grünen ist klasse weil es
im statement von den hörer steht
dahinter man muss wissen was man damit
tut mit ja und das glaube ich das wird
also auch nicht beschweren dass ich da
gut für die meinungsfreiheit weil wieder
mehr leute denn über politiker aktie die
cdu jetzt 16 jahre lang gemacht und es
ist einfach zeit das war bei kohl damals
auch so aber spd olaf scholz von dem
bündnis rot rot grün nicht immer oder
oder merkel und dass olaf scholz spd
es ist ein besser rot rot grün oder rot
ich hoffe ich hoffe grün rot
darauf hoffe ich ja ok aber
die sind schon so hinter uns
ich glaube dass dinge sagt alle redner
große jahrhundert wahl und so ist das
wahlergebnis enttäuschen dann wird sich
nicht bewegen das ist für mich würd's
enttäuschen er wird sich nicht jeden
neuen kanzler das ist schon mal klar
laupichler oder so ist er schon mal viel
wert bei anna lena hat er praktisch im
grünen weil die so aufgetreten sind dann
hat man hat sich so ein gerät das wir
machen ja sagen und robert aber die hat
ja so lauten die ausstellung lässt sich
ja sie glauben ihr es wird olaf scholz
als kanzler oder gibts annalena baerbock
also ich habe ja
ist ja raus kommt hier ist ein kanal
in liberia weg lieber gut okay danke
hier wird kanzler oder schals
ich kann es nicht sagen weil es gab ja
auch mit den funk
statistische fehler in der in der
erhebung genau ist denn wir sehen wer es
wird aktuell kampfansagen wahrscheinlich
olaf scholz ich würde ich bin kein
totaler armin laschet versagte macht
alles super ich finde auch dass nrw
problem dar aber ich muss sagen von der
union auch mit den köpfen darunter auch
was sie mit der klima union machen das
finde ich wenn ich tick besser als bei
der spd deswegen würde ich mich freuen
wenn es armin laschet wird aber habt
auch ganz viele themen die man dann
kritisieren als wir hier vor in der
woche saßen diese frage schon mal
gestellt hat in der runde da war das
bild noch ziemlich eindeutig da war vier
zu eins also vier von den teilnehmern
hier haben gesagt armin laschet und eine
kollegin hat gesagt das wird oder short
ist das bild schon die umfragen sind
krasse und die bereits ich bleibe bei
laschet als weil ein nein ich sage eine
sache wenn olaf scholz kanzler wird
haben die deutschen die wirtschaft nicht
verstanden das waren wir heute auch bei
der bundestags debatte wieder ganz klar
bei seiner rede und bei frau berbalk
michael ich kann es jetzt nicht
aufmachen weil frank bekommt seine
redezeit und jagen aber ich schwöre dir
bei einem glas wein nach der sendung
werden wir darüber debattieren die
grünen nehmen und dann machen sie heute
ist raus
[Musik]